P Ai desgraça vou embora desse filme que
filme de terror não é terror é suo
imagina Tu entra num quarto quando tu
olha pra cama tá isso aqui ó meu pai do
céu minha nossa toda vez que eu cheguei
em casa na vele do demônio tá na minha
cama toda vez que eu chego em casa na
Bele do demónio tá na minha cama e diz
aí o í que que você vai fazer eu vou
procurar um padre para me defender ele
vai dar uma resada na cabeça dela ele
vai jogar água abera na cara dela ch que
desgraça feia meu amigo ela chega lá tá
isso aqui em cima da câ diz se tu não dá
um infarto na hora não a minha do filme
age tranquilamente aí ela vê o fantasma
da menininha aí vai conversar com a
menina você precisa de meu amigo não
existe diálogo com demônio não existe
você chega no quarto da menina que
morreu a menina que morreu está lá quer
dizer o qu que o quarto é dela vá se
embora eu ia ver a menina ia dizer ok ok
houve um equívoco Pela minha parte
agradeço a compreensão e lhe peço
desculpa houve um equívoco